WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE UNREST
IN BALTIMORE WHICH ESCALATED
AFTER A GROUP OF TEENS INITIALLY
CLASHED WITH THE POLICE.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, TEENS GOTTA
TEEN.
YOU CAN'T STOP A TEEN FROM
TEENING.
THAT'S ALL I GOTTA SAY.
UNLESS YOU'RE THEIR MOM.
>> AT LEAST ONE MOTHER TOOK
MATTERS INTO HER OWN HANDS AFTER
CATCHING A YOUNG MAN BELIEVED TO
BE HER SON PARTICIPATING IN THE
RIOTS.
>> SHE STARTED SMACKING HIM ON
THE HEAD BECAUSE SHE WAS SO
EMBARRASSED.
>> Larry: YES!
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
YOU DO NOT MESS WITH MOM.
SHE WILL TAKE YOU DOWN, SON!
BUT, SHE'S NOT THE ONLY MOM
WARRIOR OUT THERE.
PLEASE WELCOME THE LEADER OF THE
CIVIL UNREST MOM MOVEMENT ANGEL
LEWIS.
ANGEL, WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW, ANGEL.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME, LARRY.
THE CIVIL UNREST MOMS BELIEVE
ALL MOTHERS SHOULD DO WHAT OUR
SISTER DID IN THAT VIDEO.
FORGET THE POLICE AND THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
IT'S MOMMA TIME.
( LAUGHTER )
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: AND-- AND YOU THINK
YOU MOMS CAN STOP A RIOT?
>> WE ALREADY ARE STOPPING IT.
MY SON DARNELL WAS OUT THERE
LOOTING.
I KNOCKED HIM INTO WEDNESDAY.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
HE WON'T KNOW ABOUT IT UNTIL
TOMORROW.
>> Larry: ALL RIGHT.
IT DOES SEEM A LITTLE VIOLENT.
ISN'T THAT CHILD ABUSE?
>> ABSOLUTELY!
( LAUGHTER )
BUT IT'S A LOT BETTER THAN OUR
KIDS GETTING KILLED BY THE
COPS.
>> Larry: TRUE, THAT'S TRUE.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
VERY GOOD POINT.
AND YOU DON'T THINK THE NATIONAL
GUARD IS HELPING AT ALL.
>> HELL NO!
THESE ARE TEENAGED BOYS, LARRY.
WHAT'S MORE EFFECTIVE AGAINST A
TEENAGED BOY, THIS...
OR THIS?
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: VERY INTIMIDATING.
SO WHAT EXACTLY DO YOU DO TO
STOP THESE TEENAGED BOYS?
>> OH, I USE ALL THE MOM
TACTICS, LARRY-- GUILT,
INTIMIDATION, WHATEVER WORKS.
IF I SEE MY BOY ABOUT THROW A TV
INTO A STORE WINDOW, I GO FULL
NAME ON HIM.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE ).
>> Larry: "FULL NAME?"
>> YEAH, I'LL JUST YELL, "
DARP, YOU PUT THAT TV DOWN--
DARNELL THELONIOUS LEWIS, YOU
PUT THAT TV DOWN RIGHT NOW!"
>> Larry: WOW. THREE NAMES.
THAT'S HARD CORE.
I ALWAYS HATED THAT ONE.
>> IT'S NOT JUST MY KIDS.
I'LL USE THESE TACTICS ON
ANYBODY'S KIDS.
IT TAKES A VILLAGE, LARRY.
>> Larry: TRUE, TRUE.
WHAT WOULD DO YOU IF YOU SAW A
KID JUMPING ON A CAR?
>> OH, I'D GO RIGHT TO
HUMILIATION.
CHECK THIS OUT.
"OH, TYRONE YOU LOOK LIKE YOU
GOT A LITTLE RIOT DUST ON YOUR
FOREHEAD.
HERE, LET ME GET THAT OFF FOR
YOU."
>> Larry: OH, MY GOD!
( LAUGHTER )
THAT'S HORRIBLE, CIVIL UNREST
MOM.
SO ARE YOU MOMS-- ARE YOU
GETTING SUPPORT OUT THERE?
WHAT DOES THE MAYOR THINK ABOUT
THIS?
>> OOOH!
DON'T EVEN BRING THAT LADY UP.
DID YOU HEAR WHAT SHE SAID ABOUT
THE PROTESTERS?
>> WHILE WE TRY TO MAKE SURE
THEY WERE PROTECTED FROM THE
CARS AND THE OTHER, YOU KNOW,
THINGS THAT WERE GOING ON, WE
GAVE THOSE WHO WISHED TO DESTROY
SPACE TO DO THAT AS WELL.
>> EXCUSE ME?
SHE BETTER HIDE BECAUSE IF I SEE
HER I'M GOING TO GRAB HER LITTLE
BEHIND AND TEACH HER TO GIVE
MY SON SPACE TO DESTROY.
>> Larry: HARSH WORDS.
>> NO.
SHE'S NUMBER TWO ON MY SLAP
LIST.
( LAUGHTER ).
>> Larry: YOUR SLAP LIST?
WHO'S NUMBER ONE?
>> DONALD TRUMP.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: DONALD TRUMP?
>> YEAH.
>> Larry: HOW IS DONALD TRUMP
NUMBER ONE ON YOUR SLAP LIST?
>> HE TWEETED THIS LAST NIGHT.
READ IT, LARRY.
>> Larry: YES, MISS LEWIS.
OUR GREAT AFRICAN AMERICAN
PRESIDENT HASN'T EXACTLY HAD A
POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE THUGS WHO
ARE SO HAPPILY AND OPENLY
DESTROYING BALTIMORE.
>> Audience: OOOOH!
>> SO NOW OBAMA'S AFRICAN
AMERICAN?
( LAUGHTER )
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
SO, HE'S NOT KENYAN ANYMORE?
WELL, HALLELUJAH!
IT JUST TOOK BALTIMORE BURNING
DOWN TO THE GROUND FOR A RICH
WHITE MAN TO ADMIT OUR BLACK
PRESIDENT IS AMERICAN.
THANK YOU, JESUS!
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: WOW.
IT'S A GOOD POINT.
>> TRUMP BETTER NEVER COME TO
BALTIMORE OR I'M GOING TO KICK
HIM IN THE DICK.
>> Larry: WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
OKAY.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
SO--
( LAUGHTER )
SO I GUESS YOU RESERVE DICK
KICKING FOR JUST SPECIAL
SITUATIONS.
>> VERY SPECIAL, LARRY.
>> Larry: I GOT IT.
WELL, LET ME ASK YOU THIS--
>> WAIT, WAIT, HOLD ON, LARRY.
>> Larry: WHAT IS IT?
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
IS THAT DON LEMON?
DONALD CORNELIUS LEMON!
GET AWAY FROM THAT BYSTANDER.
YOU AND I BOTH KNOW THAT IS NOT
JOURNALISM.
PUT THAT MICROPHONE DOWN!
BUT PUTT IT DOWN!
PUT IT DOWN!